ever since I was a little kid I always  wanted to be in the limelight I'm 20  years old and acting for me was no  longer a dream I felt like it was just a  matter of time Hey before I was gonna  get my big break  between job was a personal trainer I met  this one girl she was an actress thought  I was in love with her you know I didn't  know baby  she decided to drop me for someone else  and that really hurt people knew  something was wrong Hey was all he said  I was pretty sad a really good friend of  mine told me look uh you should really  make a trip for me  I never had any suspicion so I nothing  to work on so I zip it up and this guy  grabs my arm and he says you're turning  narcotics  I didn't think there's anything illegal  on the case I really didn't you ready  this is Opio bring it set me up  okay we're gonna hang you up to the five  o'clock prayer